>>> TONIGHT, NEW VIDEO SHOWS
THAT UKRAINE IS RAMPING UP THAT
COUNROFFENSIVE THERE IN THE
SOUTH.
UKRAINIAN FORCES SHELLING A
BRIDGE USED TO MOVE RUSSIAN
SOLDIERS ACROSS THE RIVER.
THIS COMES AS PRO-KREMLIN
OFFICIALS NOW SAY THAT THEY'RE
POSTPONING A REFERENDUM IN THE
KEY SOUTHERN UKRAINIAN TOWN OF
KHERSON TO JOIN RUSSIA.
SAM KILEY IS LIVE FROM ODESA,
UKRAINE.
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US.
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY CLAIMS
UKRAINIAN FORCES ARE MAKING
PROGRESS IN TAKING BACK LAND IN
THE SOUTH, AND THEN YOU SEE WHAT
THOSE FORCES JUST DID TO THAT
BRIDGE, SO KEY TO THE RUSSIANS.
WHAT ELSE IS HE SAYING?
>> WELL, UKRAINIAN INTELLIGENCE
ARE TAKING THE CREDIT FOR WHAT
THEY SAY IS A COVERT OPERATION
THAT BLEW UP THE ELECTORAL
CENTER FOR THE SO-CALLED
REFERENDUM IN KHERSON.
THAT'S A CITY, THE ONLY REGIONAL
CITY THAT HAS FALLEN TO RUSSIAN
HANDS IN THE WHOLE OF THIS MORE
THAN SIX-MONTH CAMPAIGN NOW.
DURING A COUNTEROFFENSIVE TO
RECAPTURE THAT CITY.
AND AS YOU SAY, YOU HAVE SEEN
THIS LATEST ROCKET STRIKES
AGAINST THAT VERY IMPORTANT
BRIDGE.
THAT IS THE MAIN SUPPLY ROUTE
FOR THE RUSSIANS ON THE OTHER
SIDE, EFFECTIVELY ON THE SIDE
I'M ON HERE, THIS SIDE OF THE
RIVER.
DE
DNIPRO TO SUPPORT THE FORCES IN
KHERSON AND BEYOND.
VERY IMPORTANT STRATEGIC SITE.
IT'S BEEN ATTACKS SEVERAL TIMES
IN THE PAST.
MAINLY THE RUSSIANS ARE NOW
HAVING TO RELY ON BARGES TO
RESUPPLY THEIR TROOPS.
THE UKRAINIAN HOPE IS THEY'LL BE
ABLE TO CAPTURE MORE AND MORE
VILLAGES AND PRESS TIGHTER AND
TIGHTER IN AGAINST KHERSON.
TODAY, OFFICIALS, MILITARY
OFFICIALS IN THE SOUTH BEHIND
THIS SOUTHERN COUNTEROFFENSIVE
ARE SAYING TO THE CITIZENS OF
KHERSON TO GET DOWN BELOW
GROUND, START STOCKPILING WATER,
CHARGE PHONES, CARRY POWER BANKS
AND SO ON IN ORDER TO PREPARE
FOR WHAT COULD BE AN ASSAULT ON
THE CITY.
OF COURSE, WHAT THE UKRAINIANS
ARE DESPERATELY TRYING TO AVOID
IS THE KIND OF SIEGE OF A CITY
THAT IS FULL, HEAVILY POPULATED
BY UKRAINIAN CITIZENS THEY'RE
TRYING
>> SAM, BEFORE YOU GO, THERE ARE
THESE REPORTS THAT RUSSIAN
SHELLING CAUSED A FIRE AT THE
LARGEST NUCLEAR POWER PLANT IN
UKRAINE.
THAT'S THE ONE WE'VE BEEN
TALKING SO MUCH ABOUT IN
ZAPORIZHZHIA, FORCING TO CUT IT
OFF FROM POWER YET AGAIN
COMPLETELY.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT THAT
TONIGHT?
>> Reporter: WELL, IT'S A VERY
IMPORTANT DEVELOPMENT, AND THE
FACT THAT IT'S HAPPENED THREE
TIMES IN ABOUT TEN DAYS IS
EXTREMELY WORRYING.
ON THIS OCCASION, IT IS THE
FIRST TIME THAT IT'S HAPPENED
WITH U.N. MONITORS ON THE
GROUND.
THERE ARE TWO SEMI-PERMANENT
U.N. MONITORS ON THE GROUND WHO
HAVE BEEN TRYING TO ESTABLISH
WHO IS RESPONSIBLE FOR THESE
ATTACKS.
NOW, THE UKRAINIANS BLAME THE
RUSSIANS.
THE RUSSIANS BLAME THE
UKRAINIANS.
THE UKRAINIANS ARE SAYING THAT
THE POWER LINE WAS CUT IN ORDER
TO CARRY OUT REPAIRS AND TO PUT
OUT FIRES CAUSED BY RUSSIAN
SHELLING.
BUT WE HAVEN'T YET HEARD FROM
THE U.N. AS TO WHODUNIT IF YOU
LIKE, AND CHTHAT IS GOING TO BE
VERY IMPORTANT DEVELOPMENT.
THIS WEEK THEY'LL LIKELY TO
PRODUCE THEIR PRELIMINARY
REPORT, POPPY.
>>> RUSS'S ADDING 25 NAMES TO
S LIST OF SANCTIONED AMERINS
WHO ARE PERMANENTLY BAED FROM
ENTERING THE COURY.
THE SANCTIONED AMERICANS INCLUDE
ACTORS SEAN PENN AND BEN STILLER
WELL DEMOCRATIC SENATORS MARK
KELLY AND KYRSTEN SINEMA AND
REPUBLICAN SENATORS, KEVIN
CRAMER, MICHAEL ROUNDS, RICK
SCOTT AND PATRICK TOOMEY.
BOTH STILLER AND PENN WILL BE
OUTSPOKEN CRITICS.
THE FOREIGN MINISTER SAYS IT'S
IN RESPONSE TO SANCTIONS AGAINST
NUMEROUS RUSSIAN CITIZENS.
>>> WE HAVE NEW CNN REPORTING
THIS MORNING THAT RUSSIA IS
BUYING MILLIONS OF ROCKETS AND
ARTILLERY SHELLS BY NORTH KOREA
TO USE IN UKRAINE.
IT SAYS THEY'RE HAVING SEVERE
SUPPLY SHORTAGES THERE.
CNN'S BARBARA STARR IS LIVE AT
THE PENTAGON THIS MORNING.
BARBARA, WHAT HAVE YOU LEARNED
ON THIS FRONT?
>> WELL, GOOD MORNING, JOHN.
THE ADMINISTRATION NOW VERY OPEN
ABOUT WHAT IT SEES WITH RUSSIA
GOING ON WITH THE MUNITIONS
STATEMENTS.
WE RECEIVED A STATEMENT FROM A
SENIOR DEFENSE OFFICIAL.
LET ME READ IT TO YOU, THE
RUSSIAN MINISTRY IS IN THE
PROCESS OF PURCHASING MILLIONS
OF ROCKETS AND ARTILLERY SHELLS
FROM NORTH KOREA FOR USE ON THE
BATTLEFIELD IN UKRAINE.
THIS PURCHASE INDICATES THAT THE
RUSSIAN MILITARY CONTINUES TO
SUFFER FROM SEVERE SUPPLY
SHORTAGES IN UKRAINE DUE IN PART
TO SANCTIONS.
WE EXPECT THAT RUSSIA COULD
EXPECT TO PURCHASE ADDITIONAL
NORTH KOREAN MILITARY EQUIPMENT
GOING FORWARD.
HERE'S WHAT WE UNDERSTAND, THE
UKRAINIANS ARE MAKING PROGRESS,
OF COURSE, IN THAT EASTERN AREA
OF UKRAINE, ESPECIALLY AROUND
THE KHERSON AREA.
THE RUSSIANS KNOW THE UKRAINIANS
OBVIOUSLY ARE MAKING PROGRESS.
SO THEY'RE TRYING TO REINFORCE
WITH THESE MUNITIONS.
MILLIONS OF ROUNDS.
BUT THERE'S GOING TO BE
CHALLENGES FOR THE RUSSIANS.
IT'S GOING TO TAKE A WHILE FOR
IT TO GET THERE AND THEY'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO GO INTO UKRAINE
WITH THE TROOPS AND EQUIPMENT
THAT WILL MAKE IT POSSIBLE FOR
THEM TO ACTUALLY USE THE MUN 96S
INSIDE UKRAINE.
AND THEY'RE BUYING THEM FROM
NORTH KOREA WHICH IS PRETTY
INTERESTING.
THE NORTH KOREANS NOT KNOWN FOR
THEIR ADVANCE METHODS OF STORING
THEIR MILITARY EQUIPMENT.
SO, WE'LL HAVE TO SEE HOW
EFFECTIVE THESE MUNITIONS ARE.
WHETHER THEY ACTUALLY WORK.
AND IF THE RUSSIANS ARE GOING TO
IN FACT BE ABLE TO EVEN GET THEM
THERE.
JOHN.
>> BARBARA, THAT WAS MY
QUESTION.
DID NORTH KOREA HAVE THIS TYPE
OF AN ARSENAL TO SELL?
AND WILL IT BE EFFECTIVE FOR THE
RUSSIANS TO USE ON THE
BATTLEFIELD?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, IT'S SO
INTERESTING THE NORTH KOREANS
HAVE A HUGE INVENTORY.
I THINK THERE'S LITTLE QUESTION
ABOUT THAT.
BUT, OF COURSE, WE'VE ALWAYS
BEEN LED TO BELIEVE THE RUSSIANS
HAVE A HUGE INVENTORY.
THAT THEY STILL HAVE A LONG WAY
TO GO BEFORE THEY REALLY MAKE A
DIP, SHALL WE SAY, INTO THEIR
WEAPONS STOCK.
WHY THEY NOW NEED THIS.
WHY THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO MOBILIZE
THEIR FORCES AND THEIR NUNN
MISSIONS FROM ACROSS RUSSIA AND
MOVE IT INTO UKRAINE IS A VERY
INTERESTING QUESTION.
NORTH KOREA IS A LONG DISTANCE
AWAY.
EVEN IF YOU'RE GOING TO FLY IT
BY CARGO PLANE.
IT'S A LOT OF FLIGHTS INTO
RUSSIA.
AND THEN AGAIN, TRYING TO GET IT
INTO UKRAINE.
>> I THINK AS YOU SAY, THE MOST
SURPRISING THING, THE RUSSIANS
DON'T HAVE THE EQUIPMENT ON
THEIR OWN.
BARBARA STARR, THANK YOU FOR